hi Gavin Dez it's me how's it going
let's play some games as pierpass we're
back right be back all the way right now
I'm gonna play this game all right so uh
it took me forever to figure out what
the [ __ ] I was listening so what I'm
supposed to do is I get it you break my
right all right I've never
aah
[ __ ] go god it's [ __ ] terrifying I
don't like that at all
I don't like that and I'll go girl
alright alright let's finish it [ __ ]
rush God just gave us harder than
diamonds
alright so now this time we go over here
and we should be fine life is life naina
oh god it's the barrels to get what what
yeah oh you why do I always fall for
these [ __ ]
I'm did was gullible [ __ ] oh the
buckets now huh well I guess I'll add
buckets to the list yes it makes sense
oh that sounds fantastic love that noise
oh great yeah I didn't need the light
anyway cuz it gave it so [ __ ] bright
how's a road here oh god I know this
[ __ ] again
goddamnit did I come from here I feel
like I came from here
whoa what is this I did not came from
here English [ __ ]
alright so oh I see it I know it's a
trap I know know it god oh god oh god I
changed my mind
oh oh hello is anyone home what oh
that's my damn Wow
you're like damn I have it on my
sandwich I'm not greedy or anything I'll
share with you
Yolo this is not Yolo this is extremely
slow mode hello English oh that is
creepy man ah let me go you mean mother
meaner she always like use your here
yesterday against you god damn it why me
ah shaking why can a pic a shadow when
he wants to pick a chill oh oh why did I
not see this
Jesus so okay I'm dead Emma not okay the
railroad
I love train tooth to tooth - don't do
coaster chill chill [ __ ] I love
you can hear me I can't really see
anything this is my protection I need it
I got it so sweat in here the [ __ ] away
on Spadina creepy noises that's fine I'm
used to creepy noises cameraman all more
pants ah hey love me some good old pay
these days very happy this game is huge
I didn't I expected like a 10-minute
[ __ ] Barry out what is Dave alright
coming Shh
hi hi hi hi
hi hi hi hi hi hi yeah oh oh you know
what that's probably Kelly that crazy
[ __ ] alright let me just pick this up
can Kelly will not be furious like a
bird just poop on the train well life is
life
oh I know it's wonderful let's read it
this place seems unreal like a bad dream
without the ability to wake up this is
an illusionary trap someone's bad intent
this goat which this goat really oh
that's awesome
which I've been which I've been followed
by wants me just do something but I
don't know what she's not very helpful
for one no she tried to kill me multiple
times
well it's it became obvious that I can't
get out why did I pick this godforsaken
Road I hoped it would help me get to her
this city face tea if you never take
shortcuts ever okay especially creepy
places if someone's reading this I hope
you'll have more luck than I did
Jessica goodbye I don't really see much
all right so we found we found what we
needed here I think I don't know if
there's anything else out there you know
what I'm gonna check cuz I'm a male
going I'm not going I'm so sorry
choo-choo [ __ ] oh god oh god
I've always had some kinky [ __ ] is going
on I swear to god this is not PG
friendly this is not peak peak a peak
friend [ __ ] I don't try it okay what
I just hope it's open now because now I
got the bone and last time I checked
with the bone it didn't really work but
I thought maybe it now they wouldn't say
the passion oh now you tell me now I
need to know it because whatever dad I
don't mm okay you know what fine
all right we got our fun oh oh oh oh oh
I got it drums are fun I love playing
with John oh so you're the final pass
huh got you now [ __ ] I'm gonna
sacrifice you to Saturn alright
sure is windy forest
[ __ ] didn't like that huh oh oh she's
in there no is something else okay you
need to stop whispering and [ __ ] cuz I
don't like [ __ ] and I don't like
whispering okay we're not good at all
every but not I don't understand so
darks I don't even [ __ ] see what is
happening in my body oh I need to go
there and see it yeah good good good
jump there kids I would give it five and
a half stars I'm not nothing there we go
yeah this is what I'm taking about oh
hello there now daddy I love smacking
butts
okay she's pissed cause her plan didn't
work
stupid [ __ ] are you gonna tell me no
its way through the branches open yes
high five now we just need to find the
bridge I have no [ __ ] clue so don't
ask me well [ __ ] me what happened this
is some strange acid I took this morning
doing all kinds of weird [ __ ] to my body
I like it but everyone else seems to get
that kinky [ __ ] effect I have yet to
have that effect give me that effect
right now place all right Bridge you
will not best me I'm a man and the man
has a man and man a man man yep
this does not seem safe at all
uh-oh it's gonna crash it's gonna guys
go Brad Rudd yes we did it
hallelujah praise the penis periods
beauty beauty
I did bring I knew it hey I don't even
have to look
oh wait I guess I will look I guess I
didn't want to animate everything that's
understandable there's no going back now
love it
Jesus this game is so big I'm seriously
amazed and freaking shocked how big oh
god its of course that's what they say
you know what they say though it can
never be worse actually it should be it
can always be [ __ ] worse that's the
better moto don't have any high hopes in
life rust this is gonna [ __ ] rain and
[ __ ] all over you sorry I didn't mean to
be so negative I mean life is good
because there's food and that makes you
happy there you go you're welcome
life advice from kids all these creepy
as trees and I don't understand this
world feels so real you know this forest
feels so real I don't like real forest I
like no wait I do
okay now I'm sexually unconfuse I mean
okay alright in here found you that is a
weird-ass [ __ ] stone a main stone has
to be like a main [ __ ] then Oh God
I'm the main [ __ ] it all makes sense
let me go ahead
oh she was kind this time I swear to god
this game is better than most free games
I played it's insane like I don't even
understand how that works
wait what did I say this game is free
but it's better than most paid a lot of
paid horror games I played that's what I
meant to say I don't know if I said that
all right let's check out these ruins
what what spitted but oh so that's what
I was supposed to do God took me forever
I just been walking around like an idiot
alright she's gonna I can't insert that
one what the [ __ ]
don't I have the stones I know I have
that there you go see they don't appear
what is that oh I had to wait for the
dramatic noise everybody can always go
ahead thank you and now I shall oh look
at my shadow and the main [ __ ]
alright you're welcome oh god what a
head then oh good
all I wanted to be was to be a ride show
instead of a pick up [ __ ] I'm sorry
Shetty it's over I'm sorry right
Oh fantastic Oh
I'm going to space for us I'm going to
space Oh am I supposed to go inside you
no no that's not it I don't think it was
that easy I don't believe it
I doubt it
or his old friend or some [ __ ]
I'm so happy right now Oh Oh God
it seems that the place is beginning to
crumble it's time to get out of here
where is the passage [ __ ] I don't know
but yes it's here oh my god yes
Oh Kelly we got to do with this [ __ ]
Russ yeah a tree has never stopped me
before - except a couple times actually
but whatever I'm going I'll be taking
the boat yes in a store [ __ ] genius I
love it
go go go go come on you can run faster
you have run fat oh ye see you later
[ __ ]
I there better be a [ __ ] boat here I'm
just literally going on a win yeah oh my
god that was [ __ ] insane seriously
Mike anxiously faded and I heard a faint
enjoyable female voice it said thank you
suddenly I got my feelings back went
wait when did I lose my feelings why
does it look like
their massage what the [ __ ] any of the
shape
I almost carried by the ambulance
walking back to their car you mean back
to their ambulance the sky behaving
clear and the Sun started shining bright
yet again the ambulance work it weren't
the only ones here there were a lot of
police around my broken car which was
still down in that dish I wasn't the
only car there I went to Moore which
judging by their condition had been
there for about 15 20 years how the
[ __ ] injection a few feet away there
was body bags lying on the ground then
my eyes caught a woman's silhouette in
the white or Poland dress standing
behind them
she smiled with the half-transparent
face with the voice and very well thank
you the end great alright so that's
pretty awesome
Wow CryEngine has to be [ __ ] amazing
this game was so much better than like I
said a lot of games that I paid for a
lot of horror game holy [ __ ] I did not
expect that expecially like how kind of
sketchy it started with that text like
that like it doesn't look like maybe the
most professional thing but the actual
game it's really good and you can tell
there's talent for horror I like how it
a lot of the scares not all of them
there were some random jump scares in
there but a lot of the scare sirs being
outwitted instead of instead of rather
some random [ __ ] just happening like and
I like how he did the things where I'm
curious about a thing and I don't think
some something bad is gonna happen and
he uses that against me or she I don't
know who made the game and my still it's
pretty awesome great horror game I had
great times I enjoyed playing it I wish
I knew it would it was a bit a little
bit longer because a lot of times I was
like Jesus Christ how long is this gonna
go on like I literally expected a
slender you know like a 10 minute 15
minute thing and it was more which was
awesome but yeah still if I know now of
what a gunman was a different mindset
maybe that being said thank you both so
much for watching this series and I hope
you enjoyed watching it I hope you
didn't have to shake hands too many
times and whatever is up I'll see you
bros in the next video
little I can be doing watching birds and
sky come read today I'll see you next
time